[Music]
all right i have this really
hilarious story so this eighth grader
in the uk he got in trouble
because he was throwing a rave in the
school bathroom
oh [ __ ] next [ __ ] level
so he had his own like dj equipment and
he was like doing a set and he was he
also had like
uh like flashlights strobe lights yeah
the strobe lights and [ __ ] and
wait during the pandemic uh yeah this is
december
yeah from december good for them winter
wonderland while class was in session or
it was just the school was empty and he
wanted to throw a rave there
so um so it was on a friday night
they're saying at dinner time so i don't
know
like um supper that's after school time
yeah
um he actually promoted this rave of his
via snapchat
and so he uses snapchat not the adults
that's smart though
see so you you just sent it to all the
kids all right
snapchat's making a comeback i heard
what
i'm not on it what why if you had all
that space why pick a bathroom
bathrooms are small well probably
because the acoustics
yeah the adult wouldn't find out about
the bathroom
true and if you need to throw up you
could do it right there that's only like
10 people it's very exclusive
unless it's like an airport bathroom
that's mad you probably have to get
there early to get a stall because
what you fill up your own vip stall
social distancing i'm only assuming that
it's at night and they kind of broke
into the school and all that and i'm all
like
why don't you just use the [ __ ] gym
it's bigger oh maybe
they call bathrooms and locker rooms the
same thing oh they're like british or
something yeah
they're like british no they said the
boys lose they lose
oh they call them lose that's true
that's the bathroom is it british yeah i
said
yeah and manchester united manchester oh
yeah this was russia
for some reason what why did i think
that
we're warming up we're warming up okay
bryn's not there all the way so i don't
know
much about this school but me just
trying to connect the dots i'm assuming
it's one of those like
like board like boarding schools harry
potter school i was like a harry potter
kind of school because they're saying
that this was like at dinner time and
then so when he got sent
home his mom took a photo of him because
like
like he's all he's rolling his eyes
it's not [ __ ] yeah and so she
got a photo of him
why didn't you just tell me it was
hogwarts right before he got
he was like gives her a rave that's so
cute he's already [ __ ] terrified too
he's like [ __ ] i'm gonna get schooled oh
[ __ ] no [ __ ] way that [ __ ] cute
ass little boy 12 year old he threw him
away
this is literally isaac's age why does
he look like he plays rugby and [ __ ]
i was hoping he would look like skrillex
i know he does have kind of acrylic
and i also have a video yes of the
wraith
it's his same equipment but in his
bedroom oh okay and
i i'm assuming this is like his little
brother or something in the
put your hands together look at this
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's really good i would not so if he
was my kid
i think i'd be pissed right because i'm
like bro like
this is school we have to like follow
the rules you want to set a good example
yada yada yada
yes but then i'd be like dude let's
[ __ ] nurture that [ __ ]
like you're good so we're going to drop
out of school yeah buy you some
drugs see baby get you ready look at you
but it's the conflict that uh
and the adversity that helps the
entrepreneurship so i'm kind of like
yeah like he's [ __ ] good like if his
parents like i'm like yes
let's discipline his ass but bro i'm
gonna yell at you while i give you this
for christmas
here's some turntables i'm gonna yell at
you for getting caught you're dumb ass
true that's uncle i yell at them and
then me and nikki are awesome
and i'm like we did [ __ ] good this
kid's awesome
well you guys you guys will be like more
stricter than this
mom apparently because she said that she
told him that he will not be getting in
trouble
at home at all and that they would just
thought it was really funny
oh i love it that was it i love it yeah
yeah i [ __ ] i'm
with it i'm going to dj my next brunch
please and then also they were saying
that uh
so this kid was saying how everyone now
the boys
in during this rave they were passing
around chocolates and energy drinks
and they're listening to christmas music
i mean what the [ __ ] kind of rave is
this
that's selfish awesome
so it was an all boys rave that's why at
the bathroom
the teachers actually took away his
equipment what yeah so as soon as they
caught him they took away the equipment
and so we're hoping we're gonna get it
back i mean i get it
you know if they make it underground
they force people to do illegal things
like this you know what i mean
they should like encourage it and be
like okay we're gonna have a school
dance
friday night he should be head of the
rave committee now go have a go fund me
for this kid i'd [ __ ]
throw throw something in to get him his
equipment back at least he got to
play his set for a solid 30 minutes
before he got caught that's part
i just found out bart threw a rave at
his high school
um and i don't think he shared that with
you guys here i did it the right way
though
you had permits well with drugs no so
like my senior year
he only invited the cool people no like
senior year at keppel
um that's when i was like you know what
i think i should be more integrated into
the school
and i was you know like when you're
about to leave school and you kind of
see people going off to college and
going off to
better things you're like i think i'm
kind of a loser and i didn't really do
anything
so i was trying to get more into going
into school so i joined asb
and then i just got out of my whole uh
like rave face
so i've been to like a ton of
underground parties and stuff and one of
my homies they have like a house crew
and then so um i've been with them to a
bunch of shows before
and at our school auditorium at the time
if the basketball
court was here the dj would usually be
down here on the floor
then there's like bleachers over here
and then i'm like why don't we flip it
the other way around
and then we'll have the dj like feel
like a god and we'll get like we'll get
trust systems and lights and
base cabinets and everything so at this
point is raving though still underground
it's still kind of underground okay
um so i mean all the regular good kids
they don't really know what's going on
so i'm like this is gonna blow
everyone's [ __ ] brains so we had him
come and set up there's [ __ ] lasers
like lights because usually you know
like
high school dances is just like rainbow
colors that go like this
and a disco ball yeah we're gonna have
[ __ ] lasers the craziest [ __ ] we're
gonna bring in
like uh those speaker cabinets that
vibrate the entire floor
and so we set it up like crazy and then
he started his set
and it was going nuts and i was what was
going nuts like the music
oh okay like the like you would have
crazy breakdown
did you guys get all the equipment oh no
because he he is in a dj crew so they
have all the equipment okay gotcha
so i got all that set up and then so i
thought everyone was gonna have a crazy
time like how i imagined
but i looked around and everyone was
just like confused what the [ __ ] is
because
i think everyone just wants hip hop
right they just want to dance because
everyone's like a normal kid
and then they'll be like
and i'm like [ __ ] yeah and i look around
at all the other high schoolers and
everyone's like
what the [ __ ] is up with this music that
reminds me of back to the future when
he's like [ __ ] going crazy with the
guitar
in the next like that exactly that they
weren't ready
it also reminds me of a playlist live
party and
yeah you know the dj [ __ ] thinks this
is epic
and everyone else is just kind of like
what i don't know man
i was dancing in the front and i'm like
[ __ ] it i turn around
and everyone's like they don't know how
to act they're like barking we're not
getting them again
you were too forward man because i
actually went to
uh uh like help out my friend dj
at a uh high school like seven years ago
or six years ago and then they
everything was like a rave oh and then
the kids were like yeah
that was normal how did you feel i was
like this is crazy man i think
i was too forward i was like they should
have had this when we were in high
school
you always want what the older people
have so at that time like the older
people were into like the hip-hop stuff
like they so then the kids wanted that
you know it wasn't ready
yeah so now it's like oh that that like
dead mouse was cool and all this stuff
so they're
making i never went to any [ __ ]
dances so i'm just like were they even
cool
did you not get asked i was just not
allowed so it was just one of those like
if i could ask their friends but not
it's more of a friends thing but the
dance itself isn't really
it's not the cool part oh i see yeah you
could go to other schools dances too i
think i went to more
other schools than um my own yeah yeah
because you could start fighting
survival gangs and stuff that's cool
we went there to fight that was fun all
i got to do was just like walk by the
door and i was like
all right mom's gonna pick me up and i'm
like oh [ __ ] i think about it and i
remember my middle school dances
and i remember teachers coming up
and separating kids because we would be
grinding it in middle school
that was fun i mean now they call it
twerking it i don't know whatever but
yeah
back then it was called grinding like
get the [ __ ] off you nasty little
perverts
no i remember that i don't even know how
to wipe your ass properly ugh
with the baggy jeans i remember like the
dudes be having like the baggiest jeans
but then they'd be like
trying to [ __ ] hump you and
everything i never did the hump thing i
was just i just [ __ ] rip it up but i
wasn't a humper not a big humper
still not rubbing genitals
this is true he does not have rubbing
genitals is nice
we do rub genitals that's cool we do not
have what's the difference
one's like this and then the other one's
like grinding yeah
it's like that tick-tock effect well
she's doing that and i'm going like this
i was asked to go to the prom once oh
you were asked i was
asked i found out how much it was for
like how did three fingers fit in your
eyes
that was [ __ ] cute you just put three
fingers in there
what are you supposed to do i don't know
usually just rub it in this way
no this way you gotta do this one
use this knuckle just the one knuckle
yeah that's probably cleaner no you know
why
because the uh skin here is so much more
softer
than this skin and this is dirtier
because you're touching things all day
but then the back of your hand i'm not
touching nothing but why three is our
problem
it's not three it's the middle finger
with support from the other two
anchor points there it is yeah i love it
so i was asked to go to the prom
and then um i saw how much money it was
gonna cost it was like hundreds of
dollars
for the limo and the clothes and then
the and i said
i gotta pay for that [ __ ] and then i
hung up oh [ __ ] well
i didn't do that i didn't do that you
could have just said i don't want to get
a limo and do all this [ __ ]
i was like why do you want to spend this
money let's go [ __ ] like to the beach
or something
wait you didn't have like a friend group
to all pitch in for the limo at least
no that was the kitchen so like if we
pitched in for
like i still have to get my clothes and
all that and stuff right
and then i was like i don't i don't know
it's ridiculous like i could [ __ ] if
you want to go on a date let's do it dad
but
yeah what was that rose thing too you
had to get
[Laughter]
can you imagine that's cheating you go
up and you bust out a croissant like
this she's like the [ __ ]
well i'm supposed to get a croissant
that's what you said right where's my
croissant i put it in a little plastic
container
yeah she's out of the problem wearing a
croissant and she's like [ __ ] she gets
the flower she's like what is this [ __ ]
no one does this
she's getting grinded on well she has a
croissant in her hand
she has smack on her wrist that sounds
way more fun
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you